imagine if billions of dollars were
sitting in a bank account
and that bank account was in one of the
most dysfunctional countries in the
world
sooner or later someone would want to
steal them
and sooner or later someone did this
kind of high-level Financial Corruptions
this is the story of the biggest bank
heist in history
for months The Economist Middle East
correspondent Nicholas Pelham has been
following the trail to figure out how
the cache was stolen it was done without
sawing off shotguns without balaclava
this was the ultimate Inside Job
this is a very serious crime by very
powerful people
in August 2022 this man Hussein kanbar
alcohol received a phone call which
would change his life
from the Finance Minister of Iraq
he said that he was hearing rumors there
are about 800
billion Iraqi dinars were stolen from
the tax Authority 800 billion Iraqi
dinars is what it's about sort of 600
600 million dollars
Hussein kanbar fled Iraq in 1992 after
Saddam Hussein's thugs detained him at a
checkpoint he moved to Sweden but he
continued to have dealings in Iraq and
knew the Finance Minister
he said I think you should come to
Baghdad and support us in this
investigation
I felt thought to be done
bar suggested
Hamptons and lawyer
lawyer together they set to work
the first day we met we briefed the
committee what we want to do
to figure out what's going on I mean you
have the bank statement it's quite heavy
thick document you just see the opening
balance and the closing balance and then
you see that there are 3.7 something
trillion Iraqi dinars missing 2.5
billion dollars exactly
the people around the table they were
like shocked
the missing bills came from an account
tamed unclaimed rebate
Reba companies were
have to pay tax in advance when they
receive a contract
which is kept in this specific account
if companies make less profit than they
expected they can claim a rebate but in
practice there is so much bureaucracy
this doesn't always happen
so for years this money had just sat
there alluringly kanbar and the team
started to make calls during that period
it's really like watching one of these
sick Tarantino movies and you don't want
to see but you keep watching because you
want to see
what's the end of it
so this was one of the checks one of the
perpetrators they took the check to our
affidane bank
does in that case they write a letter to
their tax authority to make sure that
the check is authentic
it was and it wasn't the only one kanbar
and the team dug deeper and found that
247 checks have been written in the
space of a single year
all to just five companies
[Music]
no one had heard of these companies
before
three of them have been registered just
before the transfers began
it seemed three businessmen were
beneficiaries of the money in the tax
Authority's account
but there was one in particular that
people would soon be talking about
nor is the hair nor the hair himself is
a kind of rather unassuming character
he's in his early 40s he's kind of quite
chubby
he has this remarkable Knack of winning
people over and doing it with the
suggestion of perhaps they take a watch
perhaps and then take money of sort of
easing people into a system of
corruption
but just in the sheer complexity of the
heist it became clear that this wasn't
the work of one man so I decided to go
around Baghdad to find out more
[Music]
I'm standing outside the general
commission for taxes it was from here
that authorization came for nose O'Hare
and his accomplices to receive 2.5
billion dollars
surprisingly easy to get into the tax
Authority I was rushed into one office
on the fifth floor and I kept asking
about how could this High stuff happened
as I was leaving kind of one man took me
aside and said you know you just walked
through the same entrance that North
hair came in he described how uh his
limousine would park at the steps of the
tax Authority how he would leave his
security escort on the ground floor and
how he just sort of marched into any
room that he wanted he would make the
request for a repayment supposedly on
behalf of one of the companies but in
practice fictitiously
[Music]
large checks checks for tax Authority
you needed the signatures of at least 12
different officials a process which
could take weeks
but nor is a hair managed to get the
checks much quicker
[Music]
in the background you'll see that
building with the red facade that's the
Rapidan bank and that was really the
nucleus of the heist of the century it
was from here that the DNR
came from the tax Authority and were
transferred to the Rapidan bank and from
there on to the beneficiaries
Iraq's bureaucracy is just really
flooding it it's still a cash economy it
hasn't been digitalized an income's
nozzle here and he decides that he's
going to turn it into a model of
efficiency he gets everybody sort of
rushing to turn around checks in 24
hours he gets money into the system and
out of the system within the same period
of time he has kind of everybody who had
his beck and call partly because he's
paid them off partly because they're
terrified of him but making off with 2.5
billion dollars in cash was something of
a logistical challenge the highest value
banknote in Iraq was the 50 000 dinar
bill which was worth about 35
if all the stolen notes had been stacked
on top of each other the pile would have
risen higher than Mount Kilimanjaro
security Vans would turn up at the backs
of the banks take the money then be
driven off to different safe houses and
different zones in Baghdad a lot of the
money would then be transferred out of
the country from Baghdad airport to
different Regional capitals money fanned
out across Iraq and then across the
region and perhaps even further afield
as Hussein kanbar started to piece
together the story something didn't add
up
you have 2.5 billion dollars withdrawn
in cash so there must be somebody that
counted it
there must be somebody that's you know
lifted it from their vaults of the band
to the cars there must be guards around
the bank
there's like an army of people that had
to process these payments I mean here
you have Cars full of cash
in Iraq I mean you've been in Baghdad
there's checkpoint every I don't know in
every street right why did no one report
it why did they accept it
I'm Jonathan Beckman the editor of 1843
magazine the economist's home of
narrative journalism and the human
stories behind the headlines if you're
enjoying this film why not take out a
subscription to The Economist there you
can read more 1843 features like our
profile of the CEO of BlackRock Larry
Fink on our extensive coverage of the
war in Ukraine for the best offer click
on the link
Iraq looks like a functioning democracy
it has elections and an active
Parliament but in reality nothing in the
country works as it should and
Corruption is Rife
there's different forms of corruption
right so obviously you have Petty
corruption doing everyday tasks bribes
often help make things easier but what's
I think more significant is that grand
corruption that political corruption
which in essence is the political system
it stems back to some of the decisions
made early on in 2003 you had these new
leaders who all of a sudden found
themselves in positions of power and
they needed to keep that power and
Corruption was an important mechanism to
become powerful they needed to get their
hands on the incredible wealth of the
state and they needed to ensure that
contracts and procurement went towards
their interests when you look at the
story of this Heist of the century as
Iraqis are calling it you really begin
to see that that how the system works
power in Iraq is shared between
competing religious ethnic and political
groups many of whom faced each other in
a bloody Civil War
different government Ministries are
controlled by different groups most fall
into two main camps those aligned with
the west and those aligned with Iran
at the time of the heist the government
in power was aligned with the west and
led by prime minister Mustafa Academy
but his government's power was crumbling
waiting in the wings was the
iranian-backed fatah alliance
Vata controlled the tax office at the
heart of the investigation
so being publicly associated with the
bank heist might discredited and derail
its efforts to take power
my impression at the outset was that
this was the pro-american campus attempt
to try and embarrass the pro-iran camp
and show that they were the kind of
source of corruption they were the
source of the heist that as so often in
Iraq an investigation into corruption
isn't solely about trying to ensure good
governance it's about trying to
undermine your opponents the struggling
government ensured the reporting to the
heist was rushed out
was arrested as he tried to board a
plane but the efforts to undermine the
pro-iranian faction were to no avail
within days prime minister kadmi had
been toppled
the new pro-iranian prime minister
Muhammad Sudani was Keen to demonstrate
that his faction had nothing to hide at
a press conference flanked by what he
claimed was some of the stolen cash
Sudani vowed to recover the rest of the
money
[Music]
but the stacks of cash made up just a
small fraction of the missing billions
at the same time nurse a hair was
abruptly released on bail explanation at
the time by the Judiciary in the
government was that his release would
help secure the funds that he squirreled
away but over time you know it didn't
seem that he was going back into prison
anytime soon so it became clear quite
quickly that this was a man that had
protection at the highest level it may
want to know why
nor zahair told the economist that he
vehemently denied the allegations
mentioned therein
[Music]
I am a law-abiding citizen who never
indulged in such type of crime
when asked why nurse hair had been
released a spokesman for Sudani told the
economist the release of the accused
nurse are here on bail was not a
government decision but it is the
decision of the judge
and the charges were not dropped against
him or those involved in this case
he's been widely perceived to be aligned
with the pro-iranian faction
although officials insist that Iraq's
Judiciary is independent
um
foreign
[Music]
not long after the hair's release the
government changed course
the investigation seemed to shift
dramatically from those who were accused
of perpetrating The Heist to those who
are uncovered it
for some of the scene
involved in exposing the hair
was born
foreign
the implication was that this collusion
went right to the top of the previous
regime former prime minister Mustafa
Academy and some of his allies fled to
London
barely a day went by without one member
or other of the camp contacting me they
wanted to go on camera they wanted to
talk to me they wanted to defend
themselves but they also wanted to show
that they weren't involved that there
were others who were involved and this
was a story that they felt could
actually turn the tables in Iraq's
political future
one two three
thank you
foreign
you had Direct responsibility for the
for the airport
a lot of the money disappeared through
the airport at the very least you do not
bear some of the responsibility for The
Disappearance of this
is
foreign
the more people I talk to the more
allegations are being flung around it
became harder and harder to discern who
was clean and who was complicit everyone
seemed to have mud to fling it their
political enemies
throughout his investigation Nicholas
talked to Iraqi politicians and
officials from across the Spectrum
he started to realize that underneath
their Furious opposition they actually
had a lot in common they were part of
the same Iraqi Elite they sent their
kids to the same exclusive schools and
mixed in similar circles at some point
it dawned on me that this wasn't really
a system of two camps this was a system
in which everybody was in on the make it
brought back memories of the murder on
the Orient Express a story in which you
know everybody who was on that train
Carriage was complicit in the murder and
I felt somehow this is also now
happening again in Iraq in which all the
factions which should have been
protecting the country and serving the
country were actually involved in
policing it tearing it apart
many months on from the news of the
heist breaking it was still unclear how
much of the stolen cash had been
recovered and where the rest was we've
seen we've seen what two and a half
billion dollars can leave government
coffers where is that money gone I think
what we're seeing more and more is the
money staying in Iraq which means if you
go to Baghdad today you might see big
developments the question becomes is
this being redistributed across Society
or is this part of wider money
laundering schemes but we know that
there's a lot of money in Iraq right now
a lot of money in Baghdad and other
cities uh being spent in infrastructure
and and these big big sort of projects
the fact that it was harder to take all
of that money out of the country meant
that at least some of it had to stay in
Iraq and it's now a city which is on the
move again and at least some of that has
got to be due to this highest of the
century
it's not clear if there will ever be
serious consequences for the key figures
involved in the heist
Iraq's Elite continued to squabble
and the rest of the money is still
nowhere to be seen
to read my investigation into the bank
heist please click on the link
thank you for watching and don't forget
to subscribe
[Music]